-♪ 1, 2, 3, think fast ♪
[ Applause ]
-Ooh!
-That is the fastest theme song
we've ever had.
-It's fast.
-Yeah, it's very, very fast.
-"Think Fast." I got it.
-Yeah,
here's how it works, okay?
We're going to take turns
drawing one of these cards.
Each card has five
totally random questions on it.
One person asks the question,
the other person
has to answer each question
as soon as it's asked,
and I mean immediately.
-Immediately.
-Doesn't matter if the answer
is right or wrong.
It just has to be
the very first thing...
[ Laughter ]
-Mm-hmm.
-...that pops into your head.
-Okay.
-Sterling, I'm feeling your --
I'm feeling your vibe right now.
-Don't want to curse on TV.
That's all I'm thinking about.
[ Laughter ]
-You won't do it.
-I won't. I'm ready.
-You're the guest.
I will read
your questions first.
-Okay.
-And you just answer.
You ready for this?
-Yes.
-Ooh, lighting change.
[ Audience murmurs ]
Oh, we're "The Tonight Show."
We don't fool around.
[ Laughter ]
-No doubt.
-Phew.
Ready?
Here we go.
-Go.
-What's the most dangerous
thing to eat?
-Cookies!
-How t--
[ Laughter ]
How tall is your grandson?
-17.
-[ Laughs ] What?
What is Linda's deal?
-Booties!
-[ Laughing ] Which city
are the seven dwarfs from?
-Oh, Vermont.
-Yell -- Yell any first name.
-Steven!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-Cookies!
-Vermont!
-[ Laughs ]
-Don't eat the cookies!
Okay.
-My grammar school
liked geometry,
not geology.
Oh, what is it called?
Geography! Vermont.
-Fast is fast.
This is "Think Fast," man.
Here we go.
All right, your turn.
Dim the lights.
-Lighting, please.
[ Cheers ]
Thank you.
Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-What did you text to Trevor?
-"What's your deal, dude?"
-Why are you relieved?
-Because the sun shines.
-What's the biggest number?
-Thirdeen.
-What is a pig
trying to say when it oinks?
-[ Laughs ] "Excuse me."
-[ Snorts ]
Show me your angry face!
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dings ]
-13, 30, 13, 30.
I couldn't think --
I couldn't settle on one number.
All right, here we go.
This is last round.
The final round.
-Yes.
-In this round,
we'll both pick up a card
with the same set of questions.
We'll ask and answer them one
at a time going back and forth.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-You first?
-I'll go first.
-Okay.
-Ready?
-Ready.
-Which contest did you win?
-All of them!
What's another word for spoon?
-Speern.
What sound does a penguin make?
-[ Whinnies ]
What is Bart Simpson
doing right now?
-Skateboarding.
Describe my hair.
-Beautiful.
Are you a professional yodeler?
-Ye-e-e-s.
Who will be President
in the year 2050?
-Oh, God, maybe Oprah.
That would be awesome.
What's Bill Gates' real name?
-Todd Sampson.
[ Laughter ]
How many penguins?
-37!
Say something smart.
-Adios.
[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
[ Bell dings ]
-Sterling K. Brown.
"Think Fast."
Season finale of "This is Us"
airs this Tuesday
at 9:00 P.M. on NBC.